good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you're under the age
of a hundred you have never lived in a
world where the United States was not
the most powerful nation on earth for a
century America's dominance has shaped
the globe many of our most basic
assumptions which we think of as
American assumptions about democracy and
culture and art and the value of human
life are now much of the world's
assumptions at least officially this has
been an American Century but it could
end there's no mandate that we must lead
the world forever we could be replaced
and it could happen soon in countless
ways this pandemic has showed us that it
has revealed how terrifyingly vulnerable
we are we needed masks we no longer make
masks here we needed specific medicines
we don't make those either parts for
ventilators and CT scans and an endless
list of other critical medical devices
none of them are made here anymore all
of these things are now made in China
just like our phones and our routers
that are machine tools in our airplane
parts trying to makes an awful lot of
what we use and by the way a lot of what
our military uses China has grown rich
from selling all of this to us and
that's why when we need to raise money
in a crisis this crisis for example we
sell our debt to China if America goes
bankrupt after this bankrupt from the
way that our leaders have responded to
the pandemic and that could happen it
will likely be the Chinese who bail us
out they're the only ones who can afford
it all of this is real and it's
horrifying and most of us are waking up
to it now so the question is how did it
happen how did the world's richest
democracy become dependent upon a
hostile foreign dictatorship well there
are a lot of reasons for that there
always are it's complicated but there's
one main reason our leadership class
here in the United States allowed this
to happen sometimes they did it in
secret they got rich from doing it last
night we told you about a consulting
firm called McKinsey and company
McKinsey is the recruiter of choice for
many graduates at our most selective
colleges Chelsea Clinton worked in
McKinsey out of Stanford the Buddha
judge did out of Harvard McKinsey makes
money selling advice to companies and
countries the country advised Saudi
Arabia's crown prince for example on how
to consolidate power there and
violence all dissent in his kingdom many
people disappeared after that in the
1980s McKenzie urged banks to expand
something called securitization that's
the practice of selling bundled loans
that practice led directly to the 2008
financial crisis and most of all for
decades McKenzie promoted a concept
called outsourcing familiar now not well
known then US companies they argued
could increase short-term profits by
sending many of their jobs overseas
McKenzie defended this practice by
producing in-house research in which
they claimed that outsourcing would in
the end help everyone sending jobs
overseas would make America richer that
was their claim it didn't happen only
China got richer McKenzie was right
there to advise the government of China
and it got paid the whole time
early on McKenzie even offered its
services to the Communist Party of China
at a discount while charging clients in
the United States full freight
at one point Mackenzie's managing
director served on the advisory board of
the China Development Bank that's the
main driver behind the most aggressive
and brutal kind of colonialism the world
has seen in more than a hundred years so
China rose and America declined but
McKinsey still found ways to make money
here in the US in 2013 the company
advised Purdue Pharma on how they could
quote supercharge sales of their
addictive opioid painkiller oxycontin
Mackenzie urged Purdue to use mail
orders to bypass pharmacists who are
trying to keep addicts from getting
narcotics McKinsey consultants advised
Purdue on how to quote counter the
emotional messages from mothers with
teenagers that overdosed on opioids hard
to believe they did that but they did do
it
in fact consider all the injuries this
country is sustained over the past 40
years the loss of manufacturing here an
unprecedented drug epidemic that has
changed our demographics leaders
aligning with foreign dictatorships a
financialized economy in which bankers
and private equity barons appear to reap
most of the economic gains McKinsey and
company is directly implicated in every
one of these disasters the company's
ties to the Chinese government are
especially shocking last night to
illustrate them we introduced you to a
longtime partner at McKinsey called Pete
Walker